oh it is pictures like this one that got
rumors flying at Kate Hudson and Nick
Jonas are a thing of course Nick has no
trouble attracting beautiful women it
listen to this ladies he's really good
at keeping his secrets my perfect girl
I'm still trying to figure that out I am
still on the hunt so does that mean he's
not with Kate Nick has some new music on
the way so maybe he'll sing about the
rumored romance they both been
tight-lipped about their relationships
so far you know when it comes to that
stuff I try to keep that as quiet as
possible he's great you're not gonna
tell I think you talked about but Nick's
been getting a lot of attention on the
Victoria Secret swim special rich
returns Wednesday on CBS when he arrived
in st. Barths for the show he was picked
up by supermodel Martha hunt
I've known Martha for a while so we
nearly got in a car wreck in the Jeep on
the way though it's up it sounded like I
heard a chicken back there but we're
safe and sound anything's good yeah I'm
not so sure about the chicken right
Demi Lovato is also performing on the
show she and Nick are heading out on
tour together as well starting June 24th
in Florida